this Mars one operation I think this is
really really cool so this is a project
that's aiming to send volunteers on a
one-way trip to Mars you will die on
Mars if you want to go it's going to be
the first private unmanned mission to
the red planet so there's two things
we're gonna send people one way and
they're building a reality show around
that and it's gonna be this giant
crowdfunded thing pretty cool and then
they're also sending unmanned missions
there to do some other stuff
okay so Mars one has secured Lockheed
Martin Space Systems and Surrey
satellite technology for an unmanned
mission launching in 2018 which involves
a robotic Lander and a communication
satellite so basically they're going to
set up some stuff so that when these
people get to Mars there's something
there the unmanned mission will also
carry the winning projects from an
experiment contest because they're gonna
be building this giant reality show
around it it's gonna be the first
privately funded planetary exploration
mission funding will come from
sponsorships exclusive partnerships the
reality TV show and IndieGoGo we know a
little something about that around here
at TYT
the trip takes about seven months the
first pioneers could land on Mars in
about 2025 and after the first humans
arrive in 2025 the plan is to send
additional crews every two years but
again once you get there you cannot come
back this is what the colony eventually
will look like certainly not the day
they get there now we've got a little
bit of a habitat that looks pretty good
right like very 2001 ish so this whole
thing I think is really cool and you
know we were just talking about all the
social media stuff but this seems like
technology that's actually good and
pushing the frontiers of what humans are
capable of doing would either one of you
like to go to on a one-way trip to Mars
dezzy not I wouldn't do it I wouldn't do
it but also I would want to make sure
that you actually survive the trip and
you know there's so many issues you
beyond the second or third wave because
there's so many issues with this
particular trip that they're planning so
I'm not exactly sure whether or not they
really will get there this particular
the privately funded with the reality
show is a great way to
make money but I don't know if they
actually will have the capability to get
the technology in place to do it I mean
it's really difficult to land on Mars
you've got radiation issues crossing and
living on Mars you've got issues with
food with water with whatever you're
going to carry for your fuel you know
there all kinds of there's tons of stuff
there was that there was a big Mars
conference back in May and there's some
great articles that were written about
all of the specific difficulties of
trying to land a payload with humans on
it on Mars and right now it can't be
done
I think it'd be great if they could
figure out how to do it about it so it's
great I mean that's working it's working
we're ready well you know you had I
think a 40 or 50 bucks in order to be
one of the people to apply to go on Mars
so that was a great money making up
literally hundreds of thousands of
people over 200,000 people applied for
this so before we get into the specifics
of what they're going to do on Mars what
do you make of the people that are
willing to do this that someone's gonna
say I will potentially die and root
potentially live there for a year and
die of loneliness or black boxes like
what do you make of the person that can
do it to me my first reaction is to
think who it's gonna go and I think well
they're probably not going to get
scientists they're people like that that
would actually be able to study and you
translate what it is that they're seeing
and communicate everyday a bag of crazy
gonna be you know people in prison is
there gonna be people that have a
terminal illness is it going to be
people that are that want to death wish
I mean there's just a scientist that
says I believe in this so much I'm
willing to die dedicated their whole
lives I doubt they're gonna dedicate
maybe a few years of their life and then
die off when it just doesn't seem real
to me
like he said maybe if people go and it's
successful and people are living there
and then maybe they do find a way to get
them back off and back to earth then
maybe sure you're gonna have the
scientists and the people that go up
there that can go okay I can go up there
for four months like Space Station and
do some research and we'll come back you
know but a one-way ticket no who's gonna
bury you who's gonna away who's gonna
want to be there the second wave guy
who's gonna bury you I'm gonna send then
they're gonna send a ditch-digger on the
second way by
have you guys seen the movie contact
with Jodie Foster
so you remember Matthew McConaughey says
to her before she goes on the trip he
says why you why you and she says well
this could be the most powerfully
impactful moment in human civilization
so I do think there are some scientists
that we that would be willing to do it I
mean I sort of want to see what happens
with the show people who donate to
indiegogo has some say on what happens
in the reality show so you can tell the
guys those right like like focus you go
walk outside without your mask on what
let's see what happens right they're
gonna Punk down Mars so let's talk about
that so I think one of the things that's
really cool about this is this isn't
just the government deciding to do this
this is privately funded and NASA is
going to get involved in some ways I'm
sure yeah they have to be and of course
all the you know the Russian Space
Station well that the International
thing and everything but I think the
idea of privately funding something and
then building a reality show around this
seems like you know the world
crowdsourcing something which I think
actually is pretty cool that model you
know using this particular thing as a
model for hey how do we undergo major
projects that have a global backing
behind that's a great idea you know but
I can think of other things that were
probably more plausible that it would
actually go for nothing planet on this
planet you know maybe some actual like
difficult problems and challenges that
we have to deal with and I'm sure there
are a couple that we can think of yeah
that money would go well for I'm glad
that they're doing this I think it
excites people about stem you know
science technology engineering math it
excites kids I don't know that these are
the right people to do it but at least
they're getting the conversation going
yeah and so for that I'm glad that
they're just so so joking aside about
what's gonna happen to the people when
they get up there you know every science
fiction movie ever from 2011 alien I
mean the list goes on and on about these
people exploring the frontiers of space
they always end poorly they always you
know they meet an alien that kills them
or they go crazy or you know they start
seeing things or for me I mean literally
every movie so have we already sort of
have our imaginations already predicted
how this whole thing will play obviously
starting with a one-way ticket you know
it is not gonna end well
so if you're not that smart to even
think down the line that it could end
well then you have an issue then maybe
you should go but you know I think I do
hate the word reality television show
because I think of Snooki and you know
Dancing with the Stars no this is it's
almost like I know can we nominate
something actually fun but let's think
if we're doing a one-way trip whom
should we say Chris Brown alright none
of those reality people but I think it's
more of a documentary than than a
reality show you know when you think of
the word dot you know reality I think of
you know best people sleeping with each
other and running out on Mars in the
middle of the night drunk and yeah
that's not interesting to watch alright
well there's obviously gonna be free
plenty we could send bieber to there's
gonna be plenty more to talk about that
so we will cover it from now until they
get there